Alvin Bragg is like a street Thug that
has become pained on going after Trump
correct one so and now he's doing it but
the fact that the fact that other DA's
passed on this case shows that there's a
risk element here that favors Donald
Trump or because they didn't a new guy
gets in who's escalating things
well that that could be the case but
it's not as if Cyrus wanted to get him
indicted he would have loved nothing
more I mean the guy was a total Trump
hater he would have been the darling of
the New York City Elite but maybe this
is not so much about risk as it is
escalation maybe this is that's a
separate argument though right so is it
about Trump or is it about trying to
distract from the looming currency
collapse and banking crisis to incite
violence amongst the American right so
that they can clamp down on us and say
CCC these people can't handle Freedom
they can't handle Liberty we're going to
try to raise the temperature in the room
because the American currency is about
to collapse